although that artifact and then lastly  the artifact which didn't get a cover  last week I'd be radagast blade and so  what it will do is it's not actually  cosmetic so on your your character you  won't see it however as you'll see from  everybody else it does play into your  character and for instance mine so  Amelia's have a chance to generate or  when killing a minion of the darkness so  it works just right there yes the  artifact I'll be running the mural Azure  of course that's my paper that I just  had with those breakfast especially so  this one is yeah totally a doubling down  on my void skill set here so when melees  will give me a chance to get some words  I have the heliopause bond or down oh I  have the tissue in Bengal I'm going to  see that may have a chance to generate  an orrible and killing a minion of  darkness so that'll be great fantastic  you